THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
BATES.
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
THERE ALSO.
GALGIANI.
GLAZER GROVE.
HERTZBERG HILL.
HUESO -- TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY.
MORE LOCK.
MERRELL.
NIELSEN.
PAN PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER.
BY KELSEY WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
COLLEAGUES SAY QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY.
PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN
RABBI SHIP J. CASTLEMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
BY SENATOR ATKINS.
THANK YOU SENATOR SISTER
MICHELLE AS WE ONCE AGAIN TO
BRING MY FLU TO OPEN THE
BLESSING.
A SHORT POEM REVERSE LIVING.
LIFE IS TOUGH IT TAKES A LOT OF
OUR TIME IN ALL OF OUR WEEKEND.
AND WHAT WE GET AT THE END OF IT
DEATH.
A GREAT REWARD.
I THINK THE LIFE CYCLE IS ALL
BACKWARDS.
WE SHOULD DIE FIRST AND GET IT
OUT OF THE WAY.
THEN LIVE TWENTY YEARS IN AN OLD
AGE HOME UNTIL WERE KICKED OUT
WHEN WE'RE TOO YOUNG.
WE GET A GOLD WATCH WE GO TO
WORK.
WE WORK FORTY YEARS UNTIL WERE
YOUNG ENOUGH TO ENJOY OUR
RETIREMENT.
THEN WE GO TO COLLEGE WE PARTY
UNTIL WE'RE READY FOR HIGH
SCHOOL.
WE BECOME A LITTLE KID.
PLAY HAVE NO RESPONSIBILITY.
BECOME A LITTLE BOY OR GIRL AND
GO BACK INTO THE WOMB.
UNTIL WE SPEND OUR LAST NINE
MONTHS FLOATING.
AND FINISH OFF AS THE GREEN AND
SOMEONE'S ARE.
THE HOLY ONE OF BLESSINGS
PRESENCE BILLS CREATION.
DIED OF THIS BODY.
IN THEIR DISCUSSION SO THEY MAY
NEED TO THE HARMONY AND WISDOM.
THEY DO WORK BE FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE COMMUNITY.
AND FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE WORLD.
BLESSED IS THE ONE WHO HEARS OUR
PRAYERS [inaudible]
A MAN.
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE TO OUR NATION'S
FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
THIS IS.
WHICH STANDS ONE NATION
[inaudible]
INDIVISIBLE.
YEAH FOR ALL [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES WE ARE
HOPING FOR A SHORT BUT
MEANINGFUL SESSION.
SO WE WILL START OFF WITH
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR ARE
THERE ANY PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WE WILL MOVE ON TO MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THEY SHALL BE
DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE POINT TEN SUBDIVISION BEING
THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE.
REFERRED TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
FILE ITEM ONE SB.
THREE EIGHTY SIX ED WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR MAY TWENTY EIGHT THROUGH
THIRTIETH TWENTY NINETEEN WILL
BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SENATOR BRADFORD FOR I'M ASKING
FOR SB SEVEN SEVEN TWO TO BE
MOVED TO THEN ACT TO FOLLOW.
FILE ITEM -- NINE WILL BE
REMOVED TO THE INACTIVE LIST.
ANY OTHER.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES.
FILE ITEM FIVE SB ONE THIRTY
FIVE WILL BE MOVED TO THE
INACTIVE FILE.
SEEING NO FURTHER NOTICES AND
RESOLUTIONS WE WILL MOVEON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
UNDER GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
FILE ITEM TO SENATOR WALK.
WE'LL BE BACK.
I'M SORRY CENTER WILL.
THAT EXPLAINS WHY YOU PAY NO
ATTENTION.
WILK WOKE NO DIFFERENCE.
BUT WE'LL GO TO SENATOR WILL
MADAM PRESIDENT GOT A FUNNY
STORY ABOUT THAT BUT ALL OF
SHARE WITH YOU OFF LINE ONE TIME.
SO -- BETTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SO
CONFIRMATION OF EXCELSTOR REEF
TO THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
MR SHARIF IS AN ATTORNEY AND
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE AND
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER AT CDC ARE.
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MAY FIFTEENTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SENATOR WILK.
IS THERE ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS APPOINTMENT.
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
I ATKINS.
I BATES.
HI BILL.
I PURCHASE.
BY BRADFORD.
HI COPY AT ALL.
I CHIANG.
I DODD.
BY THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER AYE GROWTH [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO -- TADO.
JACKSON.
HI JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
BY STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
HI BY KELSEY.
BY WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
SENATOR WILL MOVES TO CALL
[inaudible]
WE'RE GOING.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON NOW TO US
SENATE THIRD READING.
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS FILE ITEM SIX
BY SENATOR LEYVA.
MEASURES MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL SEVENTY ONE BY
SENATOR LEYVA.
RELATING TO THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR THE
GENERAL LABOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IS
A PROUD AUTHOR OF SB SEVENTY ONE
WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT CANDIDATES
OR ELECTED OFFICIAL OFFICERS.
FROM USING CAMPAIGN OR LEGAL
DEFENSE FUNDS TO PAY OR
REIMBURSE FOR A PENALTY JUDGMENT
OR SETTLEMENT RELATED TO SEXUAL
ASSAULT SEXUAL ABUSE OR SEXUAL
pHARASSMENT CLAIMS.
THIS BILL WAS RECENTLY AMENDED
TO ALLOW CANDIDATES.
AND ELECTED OFFICERS TO USE
CAMPAIGN LEGAL DEFENSE FUNDS
UNTIL THEY ARE FOUND LIABLE ONCE
FOUND LIABLE FOR SUCH VIOLATIONS
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND CANDIDATES. TO
REIMBURSE ALL FUNDS USED TO PAY
FOR LEGAL EXPENSES AND FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CLAIM.
COLLEAGUES POLITICAL DONATIONS
ARE MADE TO SUPPORT CANDIDATES
EFFORTS TO REPRESENT THEIR
COMMUNITIES NOT TO BE USED AS A
SLUSH FUND TO FINANCE BAD
BEHAVIOR.
SB SEVENTY ONE HELPS TO RESTORE
INTEGRITY BY CLOSING A LOOPHOLE
THAT ALLOWS HARASSERS TO DEPEND
ON DONATED FUNDS TO DEFEND THEIR
UNLAWFUL ACTIONS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA IS
THIRTY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
BY PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
BY HILL [inaudible]
HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON HI ALL RIGHT JONES
[inaudible]
I LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
HI RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE.
BY WHAT CASKEY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER HI [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BY PAN [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
I GALGIANI HI PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME
THAT WOULD CLOSE THE ROLE
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS.
COPY AT ALL.
BY [inaudible]
PAN. FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM.
EIGHT SENATOR DORADO SHOW ARE
YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM.
EIGHT MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY NUMBER
SENATOR DRAWS -- AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC RECORDS SENATOR DORADO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- AND
MEMBERS.
SB SEVEN FOUR NINE IS A VERY
NARROW APPROACH TO INCREASING
ACCESS TO INFORMATION.
ABOUT PUBLIC GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTS.
AS WELL AS PRIVATE COMPANIES
COMPLIANCE WITH BY AMERICA LAWS.
MY BILL WOULD MAKE CLEAR THAT
INFORMATION IN A PUBLIC CONTRACT
BETWEEN A PRIVATE INDUSTRY
EMPLOYER.
AND THE STATE OR LOCAL AGENCY.
WITH REGARDS TO JOB CREATION JOB
QUALITY JOB RETENTION.
AS WELL AS BY AMERICA LAWS
COMPLIANCE IS NOT EXEMPTED FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT AS A TRADE SECRET OR FOR ANY
OTHER REASON. SEVEN FOUR NINE
POSITIONS CALIFORNIA TO BE A
LEADER IN MAKING SURE THAT OUR
TAX DOLLARS ARE USED IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY.
AS A GLOBAL ECONOMIC LEADER
CALIFORNIA'S STRIVES TO GOVERN
AND PURCHASE FOR THE COMMON GOOD.
YEAH WITHOUT ACCESS TO
INFORMATION ABOUT JOB CREATION
HOW CAN WE BE POSITIVE THAT ARE
PURCHASING POWER REWARDS GOOD
RESPONSIBLE CONTRACTORS.
ARE EARNING PROFITS WITH OUR
PUBLIC DOLLARS. FOR EXAMPLE.
ELECTRIC BUSES.
IT'S SECURED MILLIONS IN
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAXCREDITS.
IN EXCHANGE FOR PROMISING TO
CREATE OVER SIX HUNDRED JOBS.
WHEN A PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST WAS FILED?
BEGIN MILESTONE INFORMATION IN
ORDER TO ASSESS PROGRESS IN
DELIVERING UPON THESE
COMMITMENTS.
THE REQUESTED WAS DENIED THIS
INFORMATION UNDER THE CLAIM THAT
THE INFORMATION IS PROPRIETARY.
INCREASINGLY RECORDS RELATED TO
WAGES BENEFITS JOB QUALITY
RETENTION TRAINING PROGRAMS.
ARE REDACTED FROM PUBLIC
DOCUMENTS AT THE REQUEST
APPROACH PRIVATE CONTRACTORS AND
SUBSIDY RECIPIENTS.
BASED ON A TRADE SECRET
EXEMPTION.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG COMMITTED TO
RESPONSIBLE CONTRACTING POLICIES
BUT TO ACHIEVE FULLY THE GOALS
OF RESPONSIBLE CONTRACTING
ACCESS TO KEY INFORMATION IS
VITAL.
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE A FAIR
RETURN ON OUR TAXES AND THE ONLY
WAY TO KNOW IF WE ARE GETTING
WHAT WE BARGAINED.
FOR IS GETTING THE INFORMATION
RELATED TO JOBS.
IN THIS SB SEVEN FORTY NINE IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
BE A LEADER IN MAKING SURE THAT
OUR TAX DOLLARS ARE CREATING
JOBS AND PROTECTING JOB QUALITY --
THERE IS CHATTER THE DISS.
HE COULD LEAD TO MORE LAWSUITS
AT SAID RED SETTER.
FRANKLY THIS IS A WAY TO CLARIFY
TO AVOID LAWSUITS SO REALLY HOLD
UP COLLEAGUES THAT YOU SUPPORT
THIS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROGER WAS HER
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
HUESO.
FOLLOWED BY A SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW WE WE ARE TAKING A GOOD
LOOK AT THIS BILL AND AND OF
COURSE I ALWAYS HAVE CONCERNS
THAT -- THAT -- IN ANY BILL
COULD LEAD.
TO YOU'RE THE LEAD TO ANY AT
JUST THREE ANOTHER REASON FOR
SOMEBODY.
TO CHALLENGE OR SU OUR OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OF COURSE.
IN THE INSTANCE OF SAN DIEGO
WHILE THE OTHER CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS.
OR OR OR SOME OF THE CITIES IN
MY AND IN MY IN MY DISTRICT IN
PARTICULAR SAN DIEGO -- THEY'RE
JUST SEVEN INDIVIDUALS THAT MAKE
A LIVING OUT OF OF THESE
LAWSUITS AND AND THAT HAS CALLED
MY ATTENTION TO THIS MATTER
BECAUSE OF COURSE ARE WE WANT
OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO BE SPENT
OUR COMMUNITIES BUILDING PARKS
LIBRARIES FILLING POTHOLES.
BUT YOU KNOW AS I LOOK AT THIS
BILL I ALSO RECALL THAT I I
SERVED -- IN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT HELPING TO CREATE
QUALITY JOBS FOR THE THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO.
AND RECALL THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL PROMISES THAT ARE MADE
TO CREATE QUALITY JOBS YOU CAN
DO IN JUNCTION WITH.
CONTRACTS THAT WE ENTER INTO
WITH BUSINESSES AND OF JUST IN
GENERAL ANYONE PURSUING.
ANY LEVEL OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OR OR MAKING A CLAIM
THAT US OUR PARTICULAR
INVESTMENT IS GOING TO CREATE --
JOBS AND IT'S GOING TO CREATE
QUALITY JOBS AND IT'S GOING TO
CREATE JOBS IN THE SECTORS THAT
[inaudible]
PEOPLE DESIRE.
OFTENTIMES ARE FEDERAL GET
CREDIT STATE GRANTS THAT REQUIRE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO REPORT THIS
SO WHEN I LOOK AT THIS BILL I I
SAW A VERY REASONABLE BILL.
THE BILL THAT ENDEAVORS TO
SIMPLY -- PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC SO
THAT THAT ASPECT OF THE JOB
CREATION ELEMENT OF OF ANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACTIONS CAN BE
VERIFIED -- WORKING IN IN --
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AS AS AN
EMPLOYEE AND ALSO AS A COUNCIL
MEMBER YOU WANT THIS INFORMATION
I DON'T KNOW WHY THIS WOULD BE --
OF OF CONCERN TO ANYBODY -- I
THINK THIS IS A REASONABLE WILL
WE'VE SEEN THAT IF.
IF THE AGENCY HAS THIS
INFORMATION IF REQUESTED.
IN ASSOCIATION WITH A CONTRACT
THAT.
A AND IT'S IN THEIR POSITION
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR THE
PUBLIC IT ONLY WILL WILL
DEMONSTRATE WHAT JOBS ARE BEING
CREATED WHO'S GETTING PAID AT
WHAT FOR WHAT SERVICES AND I
THINK THAT IS VERY FAIR THIS IS
A FOR BILL I THINK.
THIS IS A BILL WE SHOULD ALL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO SENATORS
BONE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY RISE IN OPPOSITION
SB.
SEVEN FORTY NINE IF THIS BILL
PASSES PRIVATE COMPANIES THAT
WANT TO CONTRACT WITH STATE OR
LOCAL AGENCY MUST DISCLOSE
RECORDS OF WAGES BENEFITS AND
WORKING HOURS OF ALL THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
THIS BILL WOULD FORCE PRIVATE
COMPANIES TO PUBLICLY DISCLOSE
WAGES AND OTHER TRADE SECRETS
THAT COULD BE USED BY
COMPETITORS LOOKING TO STEAL
CUSTOMERS OR FILE.
FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS FOR ANY OF A
NUMBER OF REASONS SB SEVEN FORTY
NINE DIRECTLY JEOPARDIZES
CALIFORNIA'S RIGHT TO PRIVACY
LAID OUT IN ARTICLE ONE SECTION.
THREE OF OUR CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION.
THIS BILL HAS NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES NOT ONLY CONCERNING
PERSONAL PRIVACY BUT ALSO THE
COST OF EMPLOYERS AND BUSINESSES.
IF AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
CONTRACTING BUSINESS DOES NOT
WANT THEIR PRIVATE INFORMATION
TO BE DISCLOSED THE EMPLOYER
WILL BE HELD FINANCIALLY AND
LEGALLY LIABLE FOR DISCLOSING IT.
MANDATE IN THE DISCLOSURE
PRIVATE INFORMATION COULD
ULTIMATELY DISCOURAGE PRIVATE
EMPLOYEES.
FROM SEEKING CONTRACT PRIVATE
PLAYERS FROM SEEKING CONTRACTS
OF AGENCIES THAT'S LEAVING THE
GOVERNMENT WITH YOUR
OPPORTUNITIES TO FULFILL THEIR
NEEDS FOR THESE REASONS I URGE
THE MEMBERS OF PLEASE VOTE NO ON
SB. SEVEN FORTY NINE THIRTY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING ON CENTER
DRAWS YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WITH REGARDS TO MY
COLLEAGUES -- REMARKS.
SB SO FORTY NINE DOES NOT DOES
NOT REQUIRE EMPLOYERS. TO MAKE
PERSONNEL RECORDS PUBLIC.
IN FACT IT SPECIFICALLY PROTECTS
THE DISCLOSURE OF EMPLOYEE NAMES
AND OTHER PERSONALLY IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION WE HAVE CASES IN
PUBLICS WORKS OF CONTRACTS AT
WITH A CONTRACTORS AN EMPLOYEE
AND BUSINESSES.
IN WHICH THEY ARE OF A DISCLOSE
THAT KINDOF INFORMATION ON THE
JOBS AND THE AND THE WAGES.
THERE'S NO REASON WHY THEY
SHOULDN'T BE APPLIED ACROSS THE
BOARD AND NO ONE HAS STOPPED
MAKING BIDS FOR THE FOR THOSE
CONTRACTS.
I DON'T THINK THEY'LL DO IT NOW
IF THEY WANT THE CONTRACT WITH
THE GOVERNMENT I GREATLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
ALL DEBATE HAVING CEASED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
NO ATKINS.
BY BATES.
NOBEL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
NO THE RUSSELL [inaudible]
BY GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
BY HILL [inaudible]
HUESO.
BY -- TACO.
JACKSON HI I JONES.
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE.
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
BY STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER [inaudible]
IOWA CASKEY [inaudible]
I WINNER BY WILK.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
JANE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HILL -- TADA [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
ROUGH BY [inaudible]
RUBIO.
I TWENTY ONE KNOWS TWELVE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK NOW TO THE FILE ITEM THAT
IS ON CALL.
WHICH IS FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TO AND IT OF IF YOU WOULD CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS WILL CALL
THEM ONCE THEY WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE SO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
TO ALLEN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
I JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
VICE THIRTY THREE KNOWS THREE
THE APPOINTMENT IS.
CONFIRMED I'LL GET A PUBLIC.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK NOW.
TO SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR.
AND IS THERE.
ANY ITEM THAT A MEMBER WISHES TO
REMOVE FROM THE ACCOUNT CALENDAR.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
295-174-7570. SIX EIGHTY EIGHTY
THREE AND SENATE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
THIRTY EIGHT PART [inaudible]
OF ON THE FIRST ITEM.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
I BILL.
I PURCHASED.
AYE BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
BY DOT.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE GROVE.
I HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
I'M.
AYE MITCHELL.
THEY'RE NOT YOU.
KNOW MONEY.
BY MORE LUCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
HI PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE.
I AM BURKE [inaudible]
IA CATHY [inaudible]
HI WINNER.
HI WILK BY.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI.
I IS THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE
FIRST ITEM OUR EYES THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
COLLEAGUES WE ARE NOW GOING TO
GO.
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
EXCUSE ME PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR WE HAVE A PRIVILEGE OF THE
FLOOR WHICH YOU JOIN ME.
IN WELCOMING SEVENTY FIVE FOURTH
AND FIFTH GRADE STUDENTS FROM
THE CEDAR WOOD ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
IN MIGUEL YET CALIFORNIA.
WHO ARE DEEPLY AFFECTED BY THE
DEVASTATING CAMPFIRE?
WE ARE DELIGHTED TO HAVE YOU
WITH US AND WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE CAPITOL
[inaudible]
ESPECIALLY --
SENATOR MITCHELL
FOR WHAT PURPOSE PLEASE FOR
PURPOSES OF ANNOUNCEMENT WITHOUT
OBJECTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JUST LIKE TO REMIND ALL THE
BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE AT ELEVEN
AM. ELEVEN AM THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL
.
A SLIGHT MISCOMMUNICATION THE
YOUNG FOLKS THAT WE HAVE UP IN
THE GALLERY.
ALSO SUFFERED FROMDISASTER BUT
IT WAS OF THE DISASTER IN THE
WILL SEE FIRE.
SO COULD WE ASK YOU PLEASE TO
JOIN AND GIVE A NICE WARM ROUND
OF APPLAUSE TO THE FOURTH GRADE
CLASS OF THE LAWN RAMON DAY
SCHOOL.
THAT BURNED DOWN IN THE WILL SEE
FAR WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA
SENATE.
OUR OTHER GUESTS APPARENTLY HAVE
NOT ARRIVED BUT NONE THE LESS
HAVE EXPERIENCED THE TRAUMA
SOCIAIS TO WITH OUR WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE DELIGHTED TO
HAVE YOU WITH US.
WITHOUT WE WILL RETURN TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH COLLEAGUES I
WANT TO THANK EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU FOR A VERY PRODUCTIVE
COUPLE OF WEEKS -- WE SINCE MAY
TWENTIETH HAVE CLEARED THREE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR SENATE
BILLS THROUGH THIS HOUSE.
AND I KNOW THAT -- SOME OF US
LOS BILLS SOME OF US ARE GOING
TO GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A
LITTLE MORE TIME.
ADD TO MAKE OUR CASE.
I KNOW IT IS A PROCESS THAT IS
HARD AT TIMES IT TAKES GREAT
PATIENCE -- FORCES US TO TALK TO
EACH OTHER -- SOMETIMES A LITTLE
MORE THAN WE HAVE IN QUITE
AWHILE DEPENDENT ON THE
DIFFICULTY OF OUR OUR
LEGISLATION.
I KNOW IT CAN BE HARD I KNOW IT
CAN BE MESSY.
BUT IT CERTAINLY IS OUR PROCESS
AND IT DOES WORK SO I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU.
I WANT TO THANK OUR FLOOR TEAMS
I WANT TO THANK THE PRESIDING
OFFICERS.
I WANT TO THANK -- OUR MAJORITY
LEADER WHO.
HAS GOTTEN US TO NINE THIRTY ON
THURSDAY -- AND OUR END OF HOUSE
OF ORIGIN DEADLINE.
IT TOOK EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US
TO GET TO THIS PLACE SO I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR CIVILITY
AND YOUR HARD WORK AND YOUR
PASSION AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THE CONSTITUENTS.
AND CERTAINLY TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
SO -- ONE OTHER THING ON MONDAY
JUNE THIRD WE WILL BE
CELEBRATING A COUPLE OF THINGS --
RESOLUTION IN SUPPORT OF THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT OUGHT AND
ALSO -- WHITE SUIT DAY BOTH OF
WHICH MIGHT REQUIRE WHITE SUITS.
HI IF YOU WOULD BE SO INCLINED
TO JOIN US SO I HOPE YOU GO HOME
HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEKEND -- COME
BACK PREPARED TO BE
REINVIGORATED AND START THIS
PROCESS ALL OVER AGAIN.
BY IN IN AN EFFORT TO CONTINUE
TO MOVE OUR STATE FORWARD SO WE
WILL RECONVENE MADAM PRESIDENT
ON JUNE THIRD MONDAY AT TWO PM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS.
CALLING SO WE JUST FINISH THIS
AND THEN WE CAN GO CELEBRATE.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE GERMAN MOTION WILL BE
PLACED WE RECONVENE MONDAY.
AT TWO PM HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND